shut black oh that's right I make
cooking videos now can you keep up we're
gonna make meatballs to celebrate this
hot new fresh personally designed merch
that's right you like this marzia look
at the shirt up my butt okay you can
look at my butt but no one else we're
gonna make meatballs and I'm gonna sell
the meatballs as well you can buy my
meatballs I'm gonna share my secret
recipe we got the the mints
we got the cream we got the butter we
got the bread crumbs
we got the stock potting we got the
onion patatas and the roar oh darling on
let's go okay let's see if I remember
how to cook this Oh actually you need I
need this you need this is what the soy
number one wash your hands that's right
no one wants your dirty germs on your
shoes why am I sick right now Marcia I'm
doing this from my head so if it's not
like perfect you know don't judge me
trick question it's gonna be perfect
where's the cutting where do you keep
all your stuff woman do we have a real
cutting knife where once you hey this is
not a cutting knife Lindsay
I need this one I need this one women
don't question me right now okay my
gears my assistant edger if you don't
know how to chop an onion well let me
tell you how to chew you cut the butts
first right there's many different ways
is this making you anxious man this
sucks dude oh wow you were right Marcia
congratulations all right yeah this much
better right you chopped those and then
you chop it in half then you just peel
off the edge there you go oh there's a
secret trick there's a secret trick
Hagar knows it he has to sign a contract
I just chop it into tiny pieces that's
the trick if you're gonna keep the onion
in yeah that's that flavor but you don't
want the meatballs to have like the
onions in it okay you want to chop it so
small that you're literally just adding
the flavor of the onion you know I'm
saying let's just do half an onion
I don't like onion that much
what are you laughing yeah onion makes
me say okay doesn't make me cry it makes
me sign this is nihilistic onion see
this is what I need like the big knife
cuz then I'm just gonna destroy this guy
from onion yeah this works this is how
they do it in every good cooking show
Garrett and Ramsey get out of here the
other one you to someone's curious if
we're cooking does that fool
he's Felix cooking my god there never
happens real men don't cry when they cut
the onion not a tear zoom into my face
Marzia not a single tear why am I doing
this took a little time but you know
it's worth it okay it's worth it we're
gonna go grab a custard and we're gonna
put that oh that's wrong yeah but fat
I'll get some butter you know you have
an Italian girlfriend oh you have to put
with olive oil at Felix butter yeah baby
let's add that onion let it simmer
shimmer let it do something something
happens okay there you go look at that
look at that onion we can clean up
meanwhile it's not right Mars yet you
can you can clean and cook at the same
look at this I'm not doing anything else
so I might as well just clean I'm still
the one with the knife Martin yeah thank
you
so you just want to get the onion some
color pretty much that's it then you
want to grab a bowl I don't have a bowl
so I'm using a plate and then we're
gonna mix that with the the mince we're
using a vegetable but not vegetarian
it's good it's much better I'll show you
why it's better in a second this works
the same way with regular mins basically
you get the cream oh my god it's
slipping
[Applause]
you get the cream there we go man you
get the bread bread crumbs right so it's
all it's all about mixing I don't really
go for a recipe I sorted like add a
little bit of bread crumbs if it's too
moist more bread crumbs if it's too dry
more cream but tie it up at Anna you
know what I mean
add a little bit of cream and add the
bread crumbs then you get your hands
dirty
feels good very nice you like this
Marzia you like this mmm this is why you
need a bowl cuz god damn this is hard
just wrap work those meatballs ahh mmm
see we're starting to get the meatball
should I just make one big one here's
the reason why you can eat the ball
wrong if you do with veggie meat doesn't
taste that good yet feel like it's
missing something
we're add a little bit of pepper install
it starting today's nice now forgot to
tell you you got a boil up potatoes if
you don't know how to boil potatoes I
don't know what to tell you man you're
done yeah well that's the pleasure of
cooking is that you can eat mean why no
I'm not yes well so are you so whatever
we can leave that for a while make those
taters boil while the potato boil we can
roll the balls and get a really roll
these huh look at that beautiful Swedish
meatball not stylish at all but you know
so the Swedish meatball like any typical
country dish is based on just grabbing
stuff you have in the house maybe you
have an old old meat you know just grind
that down make some meatballs out
of it get some taters from the yarn get
some you know milk that cow that you got
in the back we roll the balls we're just
waiting for that potatoes to boil you
wanna the vols doesn't hold the heat
very long so you want to time it so that
when the potatoes are done that's sort
of when you start cooking the balls okay
now we're gonna cook the meatballs and
some very nice butter
I use two pants just to make it a
quicker could it do you think I'm doing
him one you're probably right
you know what it was unfair for me to
judge Mars yeah you cook for me every
single day like a real woman blow sexist
statement but it's very nice
put it sort of low heat you don't want
to burn the edges keep them moving
very nice look at that border full look
at that it's getting there they look
great I'm very happy with them brown
crispy looking thing means they're ready
take them out okay the taters are almost
done meatballs are done we're gonna use
the last bit of cream low temperature
and just put that in there and then
you're gonna add some soy get that brown
color well so good taters are done while
we left that one that you know get that
really filmless will prepare the last
out I did it from 10 percent correct
thank you there we go did not burn my
hand at all how many meatballs do you
want murder six meat box you want the
sauce on yours Oh why we got really
thick look at that beautiful thickness
look at that thickness Marcia it doesn't
look good
- Beth - Beth Oh Mac yeah we're gonna
have some roll all right darling yawn
very nice it will contrast that the
sweetness will be very nice to contrast
all the fat and saltiness and there you
go look at that beautiful uniform she's
damn good me both ma'am
Oh perfect yes so good how do you like
it
mmm that's good very nice that was so
good I'm very pleased great meatballs
great life I'll leave the recipe in the
description if you guys want to do it
post a picture of your meatballs
you can also buy my meatballs on the
store along with this very dirty but
very clean-looking meatball shirt it's
designed by me I'm very happy with it
and that post a picture of you wearing
it as well thanks for watching leave me
like you enjoyed squat fam